let's do one more gram-schmidt example
so let's say I have the subspace B that
is spanned spanned by the vectors let's
say we're dealing in r4 so the vectors
the first vector is 0 0 1 1 the second
vector is 0 1 1 0 and then its third
vector so it's a three dimensional
subspace of R for its 1 1 0 0 just like
that three dimensional subspace of our
form but we want to do we want to find
an orthonormal basis or V so we want to
we want to find we want to substitute
these guys three other vectors that are
orthogonal with respect to each other
and have length 1 so we do the same
drill we've done before we can say let's
call this guy V 1 this guy is V 2 it's
called the sky V 3 so the first thing we
want to do is replace V 1 you know and
I'm just picking this guy at random just
because he was the first guy on the left
hand side I want to replace V 1 with an
orthogonal version of V 1 so let me call
u 1 is equal to well let me just tell
find out the length of V 1 I don't think
I have to explain too much of the theory
at this point I just want to show
another example so the length of V 1 is
equal to the square root of 0 squared
plus 0 squared plus 1 squared plus 1
squared which equals the square root of
2 so let me define my new vector u 1 to
be equal to 1 over the length of V 1 1
over the square root of 2 times V 1 x
times 0 0 1 1 and just like that the
span of v1 v2 v3 is the same thing as a
span of u1 v2 and v3 so now so this is
my first thing that I've normalized so I
can say that V is now equal to the span
of the vectors u1 v2
and v3 because I can replace v1 with
this guy because this guy I can this guy
is just a scaled-up version of this guy
so I can definitely represent him with
him so I can represent any linear
combination of these guys with any
linear combination of those guys right
there
now we just did our first vector we've
just normalized this one we need to
replace these other vectors with guys
that are with vectors that are
orthogonal to this guy right here so
let's do v2 first so let's replace we
could say let's call y2 is equal to v2
minus the projection of v2 of v2 onto
the space spanned by u1 or onto you know
I could call it C times u1 or in the
past videos we call that subspace and v1
the space spanned by u1 and that's just
going to be equal to y2 is equal to v2
which is 0 1 1 0 minus v2 projected onto
that space is just the dot product of a
v2 it's just the dot product of V 2 0 1
1 0 with the spanning vector of that
space and there's only one of them so
we're only going to have one term like
this with you one so dotted with 1 over
the square root of 2 times 0 0 1 1 and
then all of that times u1 so 1 over the
square root of 2 times the vector 0 0 1
1 and so this is going to be equal to v2
which is 0 1 1 0 the square root of 2 is
let's factor the mouth so then you just
get or just take them and reassociate
them out so then you get this is 1 over
square root 2 times 1 over square root
of 2 is minus 1/2 u times what's the dot
product of these two guys you get 0
times 0 plus 1 times 0 which is still 0
plus 1 times 1 plus 0 times 0 so just
going to have times 1 times this out
here 0 0 1 1
right that a little bit neater getting
careless 1 1 so this is just going to be
equal to 0 1 1 0 minus minus 1/2 times 0
is 0 1/2 times 0 and 0 then I have 2
halves here so Y 2 y 2 is equal to let's
see 0 minus 0 is is 0 1 minus 0 is 1 1
minus 1/2 is 1/2 and then 0 minus 1/2 is
minus 1/2 so now the span of V the V we
can now write is the span of u1 y 2 and
V 3 and this is progress u 1 is
orthogonal Y 2 y sorry you want is
normalized it has length 1 y 2 is
orthogonal to it or they're orthogonal
with respect to each other
but why 2 still has not been normalized
so let me replace Y 2 with a normalized
version of it the length of Y 2 the
length of Y 2 is equal to the square
root of 0 plus 1 squared which is 1 plus
1/2 squared which is 1/4 plus minus 1/2
squared which is also 1/4 so plus 1/4 so
this is 1 and 1/2 so it's equal to the
square root the square root of 3 halves
so let me define another vector here u2
which is equal to 1 over the square root
of 3 halves or we could say it's the
square root of 2/3 I'm just inverting it
it's 1 over the length of Y 2 so I'll
just find the reciprocal so it's the
square root of 2 over 3 times y 2 times
this guy right here times 0 1 1/2 and
minus 1/2 and so this span is going to
be the same thing as the span of u1 u2
and v3 and there's
our second basis vector we're making a
lot of progress these guys are
orthogonal with respect to each other
they both have length one we just have
to do something about v3 and we do it
the same way let's find a vector that is
orthogonal to these guys and if I sum
that vector to some linear combination
of these guys I'm going to get v3 and
I'm going to call that vector Y 3 y 3 is
equal to it's going to be equal to V 3
minus the projection of v3 onto onto the
subspace spanned by u1 and u2 so I can
call that subspace let me just write it
here the span the span of u1 and u2 just
for notation I'm going to call it V 2 so
it's V 3 and actually don't even have to
write that minus the projection of v3
onto that what's that going to be that's
going to be V 3 dot u 1 times u 1 times
the vector u 1 and actually let me just
well under plus V 3 dot u 2 times the
vector u 2 since this is an orthonormal
basis the projection onto it you just
take the dot product of V through with
each of their the orthonormal basis
vectors and multiply them times the
orthonormal basis vectors we saw that
several videos ago that's one of the
neat things about orthonormal basis so
what is this going to be equal to a
little bit more computation here y3 is
equal to v3 which was up here so that's
V 3 V 3 looks like this it's 1 1 0 0
minus v3 dot u 1 so this is minus v3 1 1
0 0 dot u 1 so it's dot 1 over the
square root of 2 times x 0 0 1 1 that's
u 1 so that's this part right here times
u 1 so times 1 over the square root of 2
times 0 0 1 1
this piece right there is this piece
right there and then we can distribute
this minus sign so it's going to be plus
you know you have a plus button is minus
over here so it's going to minus v3 let
me switch colors minus v3 which is 1 1 0
0 dotted with you 2 dotted with the
square root of 2/3 times 0 1 1/2 minus
1/2 times you 2 times the vector u 2
times the square root of 2 over 3 times
the vector 0 1 1/2 minus 1/2 and what do
we get
let's calculate this so we could take
the so this is going to be equal to this
is going to be equal to the vector 1 1 0
0 minus so the 1 over square root 2 1
over squared 2 multiply them you're
going to get a 1/2 1/2 and then when you
take the dot product of these 2 1 times
0 let's see this is actually all going
to be if you take the dot product of all
of these and there's actually I'll get 2
0 right so this guy v3 was actually
already orthogonal to u 1 they're
already orthogonal to u 1 so this will
just go straight to 0 which is nice we
don't have to have a term right there
and I took the dot / 1 times 0 plus 1
times 0 plus 0 times 1 plus 0 times 1
I'll get to 0 so this whole term drops
out we can ignore it which makes our
computation simpler and then over here
we have minus square root of 2/3 times
square root of 2/3 is just 2/3 times the
dot product of these two guys so that's
1 times 0 which is 0 plus 1 times 1
which is 1 plus 0 times 1/2 which is 0
plus 0 times minus 1/2 which is 0 so we
just get a 1 there times this vector
times the vector 0 1 1/2 minus 1/2 and
then what do we get we get this is the
homestretch 1 1 0 0
- - two thirds times all of these guys
so 2/3 times 0 is 0 2/3 times 1 is 2/3
2/3 times 1/2 2/3 times 1/2 is 1 third
and then 2/3 times minus 1/2 is minus
1/3 so then this is going to be equal to
1 minus 0 is 1 1 minus 2/3 is 1/3 0
minus 1/3 is minus 1/3 and then 0 minus
minus 1/3 is positive 1/3 so this vector
y3 is orthogonal to these two other
vectors which is nice but it still
hasn't been normalized so we finally
have to normalize this guy then we're
done then we have an orthonormal basis
we'll have u1 u2 and now we'll find you
3 so the length the length of my vector
Y actually let's do something even
better it'll simplify things a little
bit instead of writing y this way I
could scale up Y right all I want is a
vector that's orthogonal to the other
two that still spans the same space so I
can scale this guy up so I could say I
don't know let me just call it y3 you
know I know let me call it y3 prime now
I'm just doing this to ease the
computation I could just scale this guy
up multiplying by 3 so what do I get
I probably should've done with some of
the other ones 3 1 minus 1 and 1
and so I could replace y3 with this guy
and then I can just normalize this guy
it'll be a little bit easier so the
length of y 3 prime that I just defined
is equal to the square root of 3 squared
which is 9 plus 1 squared plus minus 1
squared plus 1 squared which is equal to
the square root of 12 which is what
that's 2 square roots of 3 is equal to 2
square roots of 3 right 4 square root of
4 times square root of 3 which is 2
square roots of 3 so now I can define u
3 is equal to Y 3 times 1 over the
length of Y 3 so it's equal to 1 over 2
square roots of 3
time's the vector 3 1 -1 and 1 and then
we're done if we have a basis an
orthonormal basis would be this guy let
me take the other ones down here and
these guys all of these form bring it
all the way down if I have a collection
of these 3 vectors I now have an
orthonormal basis for V these 3 right
here they form that set is an
orthonormal basis for my original
subspace V that I started off with